ein verfahren vor dem europäischen
gerichtshof in luxemburg könnte dafür
sorgen dass der christian b der
tatverdächtige im fall maddie wieder
freikommt aktuell sitzt er noch in haft
in kiel und wir haben extra sich mit dem
verteidiger sprechen können
vereinfacht gesagt geht es um die
umstände der auslieferung und ob diese
auslieferung mit europäischem recht
vereinbar ist
wenn das nicht der fall gewesen ist wird
es wahrscheinlich darauf hinauslaufen
dass man zu dem ergebnis kommt dass ihm
in deutschland der prozess nicht hätte
gemacht werden sollte der europäische
gerichtshof unserer rechtsauffassung
folgen wäre dieses urteil vom
bundesgerichtshof dann aufzuheben
und jetzt ist mir bild reporter jörg
völkerling live zugeschaltet hier guten
abend was gibt es neues in diesem
verfahren ja christian weber heute bei
der verhandlung die drei stunden hier
vom europäischen gerichtshof gedauert
hat nicht selbst vor ort er wurde auch
nur herr xc genannt aber eher der sich
in diesem ganz profanen letzten wochen
wo so viel über ihn geschrieben wurde
noch nie geäußert hat war jetzt zum
ersten mal mit einer persönlichen
stellungnahme auch präsent die teilweise
verlesen wurde
und darin hat er seine haftentlassung im
jahre 2018 am 31 08 2008 10
da hatte er 15 monate wegen
kindesmissbrauchs verbüßt und danach hat
er weil die ermittler ihn überwacht
haben hat er fast ein bisschen katz und
maus gespielt und hat sich über die
niederlande nach italien abgesetzt er
hat das heute als urlaub verkauft und
hat sich etwas schockiert darüber dass
in teilweise zwei polizisten so offen
auch begleitet hätten
man muss ja wissen er war zu dem
zeitpunkt wohl auch schon vorgewarnt
dass die ermittler ihn wegen des falls
medi auf dem radar hätten er hat er
sogar mal einen anhörungsbogen eine
ladung zu einer vernehmung bekommen und
darin stand schon der betreff mittelmeer
kennen und man kann schon eigentlich
hinein deuten dass er sich der im den
ermittlungen entziehen wollte er wollte
dann später als man ihm die darin auch
die schliche gekommen war auch nicht wir
nach freiwillig nach deutschland
zurückkehren und musste dann durch einen
neuen haftbefehl ja dazu letztlich
gebracht werden